[#SilAfriqueEtaitUnBar l'Afrique du Sud commanderait des alcools imprononçables
qu’elle ne peut pas se payer.]
Pour faire la lumière sur les tensions géopolitiques :
[#SilAfriqueEtaitUnBar le Soudan du Sud serait
le nouveau gars vraiment très colérique.]
Pour nous rappeler que même en Afrique,
il y a des pays que nous ne connaissons pas :
[#SilAfriqueEtaitUnBar le Lesotho serait ce type
que personne ne connaît mais qui est sur toutes les photos.]
Et aussi pour se moquer des pays qui ne se considèrent pas en Afrique :
[#SilAfriqueEtaitUnBar l’Égypte, la Libye, la Tunisie, l’Algérie et le Maroc
se demanderaient : « Mais qu’est-ce qu'on fait là ? »]
(Rires)
Et pour mettre en avant les pays qui se sont bien redressés :
[#SilAfriqueEtaitUnBar le Rwanda serait cette fille
sans argent ni moyen de transport qui repart ivre, heureuse et riche.]
Mais plus important encore,
les gens utilisèrent le hashtag pour entrer en contact.
Ils nouèrent des liens grâce à leur africanité.
Alors, pendant une semaine de juillet,
Twitter est devenu un vrai bar africain.
Et j'étais vraiment ravie,
principalement parce que j'avais pris conscience que le panafricanisme
pouvait fonctionner, que nous avions devant nous, entre nous, à notre portée
une plate-forme qui avait juste besoin d'une étincelle
pour alimenter notre soif d’autrui.
Je m'appelle Siyanda Mohutsiwa,
j'ai 22 ans
et je suis panafricaine de naissance.
Je dis que je suis panafricaine de naissance
parce que mes parents viennent de deux pays africains différents.
Mon père est originaire d'un pays d'Afrique australe appelé le Botswana.
Un pays légèrement plus grand que l'Allemagne.
Cette année, nous célébrons 50 ans de stabilité démocratique.
C'est un pays avec des politiques sociales très progressistes.
Ma mère vient du Royaume du Swaziland.
C'est un très petit pays, également situé en Afrique australe.
C'est la dernière vraie monarchie d'Afrique
gouvernée depuis longtemps par un roi et une famille royale
conformément à leur tradition.
Sur le papier, ces deux pays semblent très différents.
Et quand j'étais petite, je pouvais voir ces différences.
Il pleuvait beaucoup dans un pays. Pas autant dans l'autre.
Mais en dehors de cela, je ne réalisais pas vraiment pourquoi
il était si important que mes parents viennent de deux endroits différents.
Cependant, cela aura eu un effet particulier sur moi.
Voyez-vous, je suis née dans un pays
et j'ai grandi dans un autre.
Quand nous avons déménagé au Botswana,
j'étais une enfant qui parlait couramment SiSwati
et rien d'autre.
Alors, on m'a montré ma nouvelle maison,
ma nouvelle culture,
comme à une parfaite étrangère,
incapable de comprendre ce que ma famille me disait
ou de comprendre les traditions locales que j'allais devoir adopter.
Mais très vite, j’ai oublié le SiSwati.
Et en retournant au Swaziland,
constamment, j’étais forcée de constater à quel point je devenais une étrangère.
Si vous ajoutez à cela mon entrée dans le système scolaire privé africain,
dont le but principal est de retirer la part africaine qui est en vous,
j’ai eu une adolescence très spéciale.
Mais je pense que mon intérêt pour la question identitaire vient de là,
de cette sensation étrange d’appartenir à deux endroits à la fois,
sans vraiment appartenir à aucun, tout en appartenant
à cette immensité située entre les deux et tout ce qu’il y a autour.
Je suis devenue obnubilée par l’idée d’une identité africaine commune.
Dès lors, je n’arrêtais pas de lire à propos de politique,
de géographie, d’identité et tout ce que cela signifie.
J’avais aussi une curiosité sans fin pour les philosophies africaines.
Lorsque j’ai commencé à lire,
je m’intéressais aux travaux d’intellectuels noirs
comme Steve Biko et Franz Fanon,
qui attaquaient les idées complexes
telles que la décolonisation ou la conscience noire.
Et lorsque, à 14 ans, je croyais avoir digéré toutes ces grandes notions,
je me suis dirigée vers les discours d’hommes d’États africains emblématiques
comme Thomas Sankara du Burkina Faso
et Patrice Lumumba du Congo.
J’ai lu toutes les œuvres africaines de fiction que je pouvais trouver.
Alors quand Twitter est apparu,
je m’y suis inscrite avec tout l’enthousiasme d’une jeune adolescente
dont les amis étaient vraiment fatigués d’entendre ces histoires.
Nous étions en 2011,
et il devenait de plus en plus facile
de trouver des tarifs abordables pour smartphones et pour surfer sur Internet
en Afrique australe et à travers tout le continent.
Alors, les gens de ma génération échangeaient des messages
sur cette plateforme qui ne demande que 140 signes et un peu de créativité.
Pendant nos longs trajets vers le bureau,
pendant les cours durant lesquels certains d’entre nous
auraient dû être plus attentifs, pendant nos pauses-déjeuner,
nous communiquions autant que possible
à propos de la réalité quotidienne de la jeunesse africaine.
Mais bien évidemment, ce luxe n’était pas accessible à tout le monde.
Ce qui signifie que si vous étiez une adolescente au Boswana
et que vous souhaitiez passer du bon temps sur Internet,
vous deviez, premièrement, twitter en anglais et deuxièmement,
suivre plus que les trois autres personnes connectées que vous connaissiez.
Vous deviez suivre des gens en Afrique du Sud, au Zimbabwe, au Ghana, au Nigeria.
Et d’un coup, le monde entier s’ouvrait.
Et mon univers s’est ouvert.
J’ai suivi des Africains très intéressants qui voyageaient à travers le continent,
et les postaient en ligne sous le hashtag #MonAfrique.
Parce qu’à l’époque,
si vous recherchiez le mot « Afrique » sur Twitter ou Google,
ou tout autre média social,
vous pouviez croire que le continent tout entier n’était qu’un album photo d’animaux
et d’hommes blancs qui buvaient des cocktails dans des resorts.
(Rires)
Mais les Africains utilisèrent cette plateforme
pour reprendre un peu l’initiative dans le domaine du tourisme.
C’était des Africains qui se prenaient en photo sur les plages du Nigeria
ou dans les bars à cocktails de Nairobi.
Et c’était les mêmes Africains que je commençais à rencontrer
lors de mes propres voyages à travers le continent.
Nous discutions de littérature africaine, de politique, d'économie.
Mais quasiment à chaque fois, invariablement,
nous finissions par parler de Twitter.
Et c’est à ce moment que j’ai réalisé son importance.
Nous étions au centre de quelque chose d’extraordinaire,
puisque pour la première fois,
de jeunes Africains pouvaient discuter du futur du continent en temps réel,
sans contrainte de frontières, d’argent et sans la surveillance des gouvernements.
Parce que, ce que beaucoup ne savent pas,
c’est que beaucoup d’Africains connaissent moins de choses
à propos de l’Afrique dans son ensemble, que les Occidentaux.
Parfois c’est un accident
mais parfois c’est une stratégie.
Par exemple, durant l'apartheid en Afrique du Sud,
les Sud-Africains noirs étaient constamment bombardés
avec le message que tout pays gouverné par des personnes noires
était voué à l'échec.
Et cela dans le but de les convaincre
qu'ils étaient mieux lotis sous la domination blanche écrasante
que s'ils vivaient dans un pays libre et dirigé par les Noirs.
Ajoutez à cela le système éducatif colonialiste et archaïque africain,
dont nous avons hérité, inchangé depuis les années 1920
et à l'âge de 15 ans, je pouvais citer les différentes causes
de toutes les guerres qui ont eu lieu en Europe ces 200 dernières années,
mais je ne connaissais pas le nom du président du pays voisin.
Et pour moi, cela n'a pas de sens,
car qu'on le veuille ou non,
le sort des Africains est étroitement lié.
Quand une catastrophe survient, quand le chaos survient,
nous en subissons tous les conséquences.
Quand les Burundais fuient l'instabilité politique,
c'est chez nous,
les autres pays africains, qu'ils viennent.
L'Afrique possède six des plus grands centres de réfugiés au monde.
Ce qui était autrefois un problème burundais
devient un problème africain.
Alors, selon moi, il n'y a pas de problèmes soudanais,
de problèmes sud-africains ou de problèmes kényans.
Uniquement des problèmes africains,
parce qu'au bout du compte, nous partageons le chaos.
Alors si nous savons partager les problèmes,
ne pouvons-nous pas aussi partager les succès ?
Comment faire ?
Eh bien, sur le long terme,
nous devrions viser à développer le commerce interafricain,
supprimer les frontières et faire pression sur les dirigeants
afin qu'ils mettent en œuvre les accords régionaux qu'ils ont déjà signés.
Mais je pense que le meilleur moyen pour que l'Afrique partage ses réussites
serait de favoriser ce que j'appelle le panafricanisme social.
Le panafricanisme politique existe déjà,
alors je n'invente rien de vraiment nouveau.
Mais le panafricanisme politique
est surtout une unité africaine pour les élites politiques.
Et qui en profite ?
Eh bien, les dirigeants africains, presque exclusivement.
Moi, ce dont je parle,
c'est le panafricanisme des Africains ordinaires.
Les jeunes Africains comme moi,
nous débordons d'une énergie créatrice,
d'idées novatrices.
Mais avec une mauvaise gouvernance et des institutions instables,
tout ce potentiel pourrait se perdre.
Sur un continent où de nombreux dirigeants
sont au pouvoir depuis plus longtemps
que l'âge moyen de la population,
nous avons désespérément besoin de quelque chose de nouveau,
quelque chose qui fonctionne.
Et je pense que cette nouveauté, c'est le panafricanisme social.
Je rêve que la jeunesse africaine
rejette les frontières et les conditions qui tuent notre innovation.
Je rêve que la jeunesse africaine trouve une idée géniale
au lieu de dire : « Ça ne marchera pas dans mon pays. »
et jette l'éponge.
Je rêve que la jeunesse africaine commence à comprendre
que le continent tout entier est notre toile blanche, notre maison.
Grâce à Internet, nous pouvons commencer à réfléchir d'une façon coopérative,
nous pouvons commencer à innover ensemble.
En Afrique, il existe un proverbe : « Qui veut voyager vite voyage seul
mais qui veut voyager loin voyage en groupe. »
Et je crois que le panafricanisme social sera notre façon de voyager loin ensemble.
Et c'est déjà le cas.
L'accès à ces réseaux en ligne a donné à la jeunesse africaine
une chose que nous devions auparavant acquérir par la violence : une voix.
Nous avons maintenant une plate-forme.
Auparavant, si vous souhaitiez entendre la jeunesse africaine,
vous deviez attendre que le Ministre de la Jeunesse de 65 ans
(Rires)
se réveille le matin,
prenne ses médicaments pour les brûlures d'estomac
et qu'il vous dévoile ses plans pour votre génération
d'ici à 20 ans.
Auparavant, si vous vouliez être entendu par votre gouvernement quasi tyrannique,
on vous poussait à manifester, en subir les conséquences
et à croiser les doigts pour qu'un journal,
quelque part en occident attire l'attention de quelqu'un.
Mais maintenant nous pouvons nous soutenir mutuellement,
d'une façon qui était autrefois impossible.
Nous soutenons les étudiants sud-africains
qui protestent contre des frais universitaires trop élevés.
Nous soutenons les femmes du Zimbabwe qui manifestent devant le parlement.
Nous soutenons les journalistes angolais détenus illégalement.
Pour la toute première fois,
la souffrance et l'aspiration africaines
sont visibles
pour ceux qui peuvent les comprendre le mieux :
les autres Africains.
Je crois qu'avec une pensée panafricaniste sociale
et l'utilisation de l'outil Internet,
nous pouvons commencer à nous secourir les uns les autres,
et au bout du compte, nous sauver nous-mêmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)